[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute gibt es ein richtig leckeres und einfaches
Suppenrezept aus meiner Kindheit:
Köfteli Çorba,
also Suppe mit kleinen Frikadellen,
mit kleinen Bällchen.
Und ich mache die Suppe im Prinzip so,
wie meine Mama sie immer für uns gemacht hat,
mit dem Unterschied, dass ich sie etwas würziger mache.
Meine Mama hat immer die Suppe
ohne Zwiebeln und ohne Knoblauch gemacht.
Denn wir mochten das als Kind einfach nicht.
Also ich wollte immer auf keine Zwiebel beißen
und auf keinen Knoblauch beißen.
Aber jetzt so im Erwachsenenalter
schmeckt es natürlich besser,
wenn sie etwas würziger ist.
Und,
wenn ihr die Zwiebel und Knoblauch fein genug macht,
merken es die Kinder erst gar nicht.
Also Samira und Ela lieben die Suppe.
Sie essen sie total gerne.
Superschnell zubereitet.
Vor allem habe ich Hackfleisch
auch gerne immer im Gefrierschrank.
Das heißt, ich kann die Suppe immer zubereiten.
Und ihr braucht dafür nur wenige Zutaten.
Ich habe hier jetzt
250 Gramm Hackfleisch vom Rind,
eine Zwiebel und eine Knoblauchzehe,
etwas Salz und Pfeffer,
100 Gramm Mehl.
Hier habe ich dann noch 30 Gramm Butter,
etwas Wasser natürlich,
Salz und Pfeffer.
Ich nehme hier noch eine Karotte,
Zitronensaft
und Suppennudeln.
Für mich ist jetzt ein bisschen außergewöhnlich,
die Zutaten vorher abzumessen.
Denn Suppenrezepte, die
mache ich halt immer nach Gefühl.
So, wie es meine Mama immer gemacht hat.
Aber für euch messe ich natürlich alles ab.
Also ich nehme jetzt einfach eine feine Küchenreibe,
reibe die Knoblauchzehe und auch die Zwiebel fein.
So merkt man keine Stücke.
Ihr könnt sie auch kurz in einem Mixer zerkleinern.
[Musik]
Für die Zwiebel war die Reibe ein bisschen zu fein.
Da nehme ich jetzt die hier.
[Musik]
Jetzt kommt hier noch Salz und Pfeffer dazu.
Und dann einfach ganz kurz verkneten.
Wo ist jetzt meine kleine Helferin, die Ela?
Die wollte mir helfen.
Ja.
Hat mich veräppelt.
Jetzt wollte mir die Ela eigentlich helfen.
Na ja.
Jetzt nehme ich das Mehl.
Das kommt hier in einen Teller.
Und jetzt formt ihr lauter kleine Hackbällchen,
so etwa einen Zentimeter groß,
und wälzt sie dann im Mehl.
Deswegen gebe ich die hier in so einen Teller rein.
Da kann ich nämlich gleich schütteln
und dann sind sie schon komplett bedeckt.
[Musik]
Wenn die Fleischbällchen dann soweit sind,
könnt ihr hier schon mal
die Butter in einem großen Topf erwärmen.
Da nehmt ihr jetzt entweder einen Gusseisentopf
oder einen beschichteten,
damit die Hackbällchen einfach nicht so sehr
anbrennen und ankleben.
Oder ihr nehmt einfach ein bisschen mehr Fett,
wenn ihr einen Edelstahltopf habt.
Jetzt kommen hier die Bällchen rein
und werden rundherum knusprig angebraten.
Je nachdem, wie viel Fett euer Hackfleisch hat,
kann es sein, dass ihr jetzt noch ein bisschen Butter braucht.
Oder
es reicht dann eben schon von der Fettmenge her.
Denn die Fleischbällchen verlieren ja auch
gleich noch so ein bisschen Fett.
Das Mehl siebe ich aber jetzt so ein bisschen ab,
das überschüssige.
Ich merke bei mir, ich brauche noch ein bisschen Fett.
Daher gebe ich noch Butter dazu.
Dann kann ich schon mal die Karotte schälen.
Und jetzt den Topf eher schwenken, nicht so sehr rühren,
damit die Bällchen einfach nicht zerstört werden.
Das dauert jetzt so etwa vier bis fünf Minuten,
bis sie schön knusprig sind.
[Musik]
Jetzt nehme ich die Bällchen kurz raus.
Okay. Ich brauche noch mal ein bisschen Butter.
Ich habe da...
Ich habe da so ein Buttergefäß,
was ich immer direkt auf Abruf hier bereitstelle.
Ich brauche jetzt nämlich noch ein bisschen Butter
für eine Mehlschwitze.
Dann kommt jetzt hier Mehl dazu,
so circa zwei Esslöffel.
Ich schreibe euch im Rezept
einfach eine etwas kleinere Mehlmenge.
Denn,
dass das so genau aufgeht.
Dann habt ihr es nämlich perfekt für die Suppe
und nichts übrig.
Jetzt kurz anschwitzen,
so etwa eine Minute.
Guckt mal.
Einfach so, bis es so eine hellbraune Farbe bekommt.
Dann direkt mit Wasser ablöschen
und schön aufkochen lassen.
Zum Aufkochen gebe ich jetzt einfach kurz den Deckel drauf.
Das geht nämlich schneller.
Und ich kann in der Zwischenzeit
schon mal die Karotte raspeln.
Die mache ich einfach hier mit dazu.
Einfach in so Juliennestifte, nicht zu fein.
[Musik]
Ihr könnt auch eine größere Schale nehmen.
Wie immer.
[Musik]
Und dann immer den Restehalter,
damit eure Finger
heil bleiben.
Als Nächstes jetzt mit Salz und Pfeffer abschmecken.
Dann die Suppennudeln dazu.
Die brauchen jetzt nämlich am längsten.
Und bei der Suppe jetzt ganz, ganz, ganz wichtig:
die Zitrone.
Die Suppe ist nämlich so ein bisschen säuerlich-
würzig.
Klingt vielleicht ungewöhnlich.
Huch!
Voll
überall Zitronensaft verteilt.
Und wirklich mit der Zitrone auch nicht sparen!
Okay?
Das war jetzt aber eine große Zitrone.
Daher nur
drei Viertel der Zitrone.
Der Rest landet auf mir.
Und jetzt gebe ich hier einfach noch
die Hackbällchen und die Karotten mit dazu,
lasse die Suppe noch für etwa zehn Minuten etwa köcheln
oder so lange, bis eben die Nudeln gar sind,
und dann
habe ich alles drin.
Dann können wir verkosten.
[Musik]
Jetzt können wir die Suppe probieren.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Und das ist eine meiner absoluten, absoluten
Lieblingssuppen.
Es gibt nicht viele Suppen, die ich mag.
Obwohl eigentlich, Suppe mag ich immer, aber...
Ja. Nee.
Erst mag ich sie nicht.
Und dann esse ich sie und dann mag ich sie.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Gell?
>> SALLY: Weil, wenn ich sage,
"Schatz, es gibt heute Suppe", dann ist immer so:
"Och."
Die Kinder: "Yay!"
Die Kinder, die jubeln.
>> MURAT: Die Kinder, die essen voll gerne Suppe.
>> SALLY: Jeden Tag gibt es Suppe.
>> MURAT: Ohne Spaß. Echt.
>> SALLY: Und ich finde auch,
also ich habe das von daheim so gelernt
und bei euch zu Hause war es genauso.
Das weiß ich, weil deine Mama auch Suppen liebt.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Suppe gibt es bei uns,
bei meiner Mama jeden Tag.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Weil die Suppe einfach den Magen aufwärmt
und
>> SALLY: dich schon vorbereitet auf das Essen.
>> MURAT: es flüssig ist.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Ist flüssig.
>> SALLY: Ja. Und es bereitet dich halt aufs Essen vor.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Es ist schnell.
>> MURAT: Und du isst dann nicht so viel, also
>> SALLY: Genau.
>> MURAT: es ist schon ein Sättigungsgefühl da.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Und ich finde es genial. Wirklich.
Ich bin mir auch ganz sicher...
>> SALLY: Ich liebe die Suppe!
>> MURAT: Oh, ich liebe die Suppe auch!
Also die meisten, wo es noch nicht gegessen haben...
>> SALLY: Und ich würde jetzt einfach gerne
so nach und nach ein paar Suppenrezepte einfach machen,
weil ich finde, zu jedem Menü,
zu jedem Hauptgericht gehört einfach eine Suppe vorweg.
>> MURAT: Esst Suppe! Und es ist wirklich günstig.
Weil ganz ehrlich, Suppe und Brot.
Genial!
Dann hast du auch
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: wirklich viel Geld gespart.
Und es ist wirklich
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: eine vollwertige Mahlzeit.
>> SALLY: Und die ist so leicht säuerlich.
Ich würde mir jetzt noch Chili darauf machen.
Aber
>> MURAT: Boah, ich liebe das!
>> SALLY: die Kinder essen es halt ohne Chili.
>> MURAT: Dieses Säuerliche!
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: So genial!
Und
>> SALLY: Die Karotte noch drin.
>> MURAT: kann man die eigentlich auch leicht veganisieren?
>> SALLY: Gut, natürlich geben jetzt hier
die Fleischbällchen den Geschmack.
>> MURAT: Hm.
Aber,
was ich mit dem Volkan...
>> MURAT: Okay. Kannst aufhören. Das war nur eine Frage.
>> SALLY: Nee.
Was ich mit dem Volkan voll oft mache, ist
wenn wir Gemüsereste haben,
auch mal Salat zum Beispiel,
– und irgendwie ist keiner gerne Salat vom Vortag,
weil der so matschig wird –
dann braten wir das einfach in der Pfanne an.
Ganz lange.
Und dann wird es püriert.
Und dann kannst du ja einfach gleich so weitermachen
und dann ist es auch wie Hackbällchen.
>> MURAT: Ich habe so geschmatzt.
>> SALLY: Ein bisschen Haferflocken dazu.
>> MURAT: Richtig genial! Wirklich!
Für diese Suppe wird euch jeder lieben!
>> SALLY: Es fehlt ein bisschen Salz.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ein Tick.
Aber
>> MURAT: Mhm!
>> SALLY: ansonsten
perfekt.
>> MURAT: Absolut nicht!
>> SALLY: Ich mag es so säuerlich.
>> MURAT: Weil ich tue immer Meersalz,
also mehr Salz, aber brauchst du nicht.
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> MURAT: Mmh!
Also
probiert es gerne aus.
Ihr könnt ja mal schreiben,
ob ihr gerne Suppen mögt oder nicht,
ob ich mehr Rezepte dazu machen soll,
und vielleicht auch, was eure Lieblingssuppe ist.
Wenn ihr eine Lieblingssuppe habt,
schreibt es auch gerne rein.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Dann machen wir wirklich
so eine Suppenstrecke.
Hm?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Also bis zum nächsten Mal!
Und guten Appetit!
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Tschüss!
>> MURAT: Ein Hoch auf die Suppen!
Übrigens
– ah, noch ganz kurz –
in der Türkei
gibt es einfach nur Restaurants,
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Çorbacı.
>> MURAT: Nur Suppen.
>> SALLY: Ist genial!
>> MURAT: Genau!
Einfach, es gibt ganz, ganz viele Restaurants,
>> MURAT: wo es nur Suppen gibt.
>> SALLY: Und da gehst du dann hin
>> SALLY: und isst einfach eine Suppe und
>> MURAT: Genial!
>> SALLY: die wärmt dich auf und...
>> MURAT: Ja.
Es muss ja nicht immer ein Steak sein.
Ihr könnt das Steak auch klein machen in Hackbällchen
und dann könnt ihr es in eine Suppe reinwerfen.
Geht auch.
Macht es gut!
Tschüss!
>> SALLY: Tschüss!
>> MURAT: Wahnsinn!
Und jetzt? Noch was?
Noch mal eine Suppe?
>> SALLY: Ja. Ich esse jetzt noch eine Suppe.
>> MURAT: Ein cooles Brot noch dazu?
>> SALLY: Hm.
Ich habe sogar gerade eins gebacken.
>> MURAT: Oh, cool!
>> SALLY: Ich hole es und mache es dir dazu.
>> MURAT: Ich bin im Paradies!
>> SALLY: Wie schon seit zwölf Jahren, Murat.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Komm, hol ein Schneidebrett.
Dann scheide ich es dir.
>> MURAT: Guck mal. Wahnsinn, oder?
Hey, echt. Wahnsinn!
Oder?
So.
>> SALLY: Ich habe gebacken.
>> MURAT: Ich brauche jetzt nur noch einen Flugzeugträger.
Könntest du auch noch holen, Sally.
Ah, im Backofen habe ich auch noch Poğaça.
>> MURAT: Poğaça hat sie auch noch gebacken!
Mein Gott! Leute, das ist wie Weihnachten,
Ostern, Ramadan,
Dortmund wird Meister zusammen!
So.
Oh!
Hey Leute,
Brot und Suppe!
So genial!
Und nicht teuer! Wirklich!
Brot,
ein Euro
vielleicht beim Backen, die Zutaten,
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: denke ich mal, wahrscheinlich.
>> SALLY: Nicht mal.
>> MURAT: Nicht mal.
Und dann die Suppe.
Oh!
Ich hätte es mir nicht besser erträumen lassen können.
>> SALLY: Bitte schön.
>> MURAT: Mmh!
Frisches Brot!
>> SALLY: So.
Ich setze mich aber zum Essen.
Tschüss!
>> MURAT: Ja.
Boah!
Tschüss!
[Musik]